HOUR OR MORE RIGHT NOW, RAINING
HEAVILY.
THEY COULD GET 6 TO 10 INCHES OF
RAIN HERE.
BUT THE AREA OF MAJOR CONCERN,
EVEN AS THIS HURRICANE MOVES
INLAND TOWARD GEORGIA, STILL AS
A HURRICANE, THE MAJOR AREAS OF
CONCERN ARE ALLOWING THE FLORIDA
GULF COAST FROM TAMPA ALL THE
WAY UP THROUGH THE BIG BEND
WHERE THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
HISTORIC AND DEVASTATING STORM
SURGE.
I WANT TO GO RIGHT TO BILL WEIR
IN STEINHATCHEE IN FLORIDA.
HE'S ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF
FROM WHERE I AM NOW, BUT IT'S A
WORLD AWAY IN TERMS OF
DEVASTATION.
BILL, JUST DESCRIBE WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING.
>> Reporter: JOHN, THE GOOD NEWS
IS, IT SEEMS LIKE THE SURGE HAS
CRESTED HERE IN STEINHATCHEE.
YOU CAN SEE THIS LINE OF DEBRIS,
THERE'S SOME BOXES AND LOGS
HERE.
IT HAS BEEN RECEDING EVER SINCE.
BUT THE DEVASTATION, IT IS
LEAVING BEHIND IS OBVIOUS.
THIS IS THE DOCKSIDE GRILL HERE.
THE STEINHATCHEE RIVER RUSHED
ITS BANKS.
WE KNEW THAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT NORMALLY RUNS FROM EAST TO
WEST.
WE'RE LOOKING SOUTH RIGHT NOW.
THE FORCE OF THE DIRTY SIDE OF
THE STORM HAS BEEN FORCING SO
MUCH WATER UPSTREAM AGAINST THE
CURRENT HERE AND THE VICTIMS OF
THAT ARE ALL OF THESE FISHING
COMMUNITY VILLAGES, CONDO
COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT
AROUND THE CORNER THIS WAY.
MOST OF THE TOWN IS BEHIND US ON
HIGHER GROUND.
SO THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
BUT WHERE YOU WERE YESTERDAY,
JOHN, THE MARINA, ALL OF THAT WE
FEAR MIGHT HAVE BEEN WIPED OUT
AS IT'S THE FIRST BEND IN THE
RIVER COMING OFF OF THE GULF OF
MEXICO RIGHT HERE.
THE FAMILY, THE COUPLE WHO OWNS
THIS MARINA, YOU CAN SEE THEIR
MOOD SHIFT FROM HOPEFUL EARLY IN
THE MORNING TO MORE RESIGNED AS
THE DESTRUCTION BECOMES OBVIOUS
HERE.
BUT WE'RE ALSO STARTING TO SEE
PEOPLE DRIVE AROUND WHICH IS
PROBABLY NOT THE WISEST MOVE
RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE STILL GUST THAT IS
KICKING UP.
NOT AS BAD AS WE SAW A FEW HOURS
AGO, BUT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE'S INSTINCT TO WANT TO
CHECK OUT THE DAMAGE, SEE WHAT
SURVIVED, WHAT DIDN'T.
TOO SOON FOR THAT TO SAY THE
LEAST.
JOHN?
>> Reporter: ALL RIGHT.
BILL WEIR.
AT THE TOP, JUST TO BE CLEAR,
YOU SAID FOR NOW, AT LEAST, THE
SURGE SEEMS TO BE GOING THE
OTHER DIRECTION?
I KNOW THE TIDE COULD STILL COME
IN MORE.
BUT FOR NOW, THE WORST SEEMS TO
HAVE PASSED?
>> YES.
YOU CAN SEE -- IT'S A VERY CLEAR
LINE WHERE THE HIGH WATERMARK
LEFT ITS DEBRIS THERE AND IT HAS
BEEN RECEDING NOW FAIRLY
STEADILY.
ABOUT AS FAST AS IT CAME UP.
AT WHAT POINT IT WILL LEVEL OFF,
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT THE WIND IS STILL HOLDING
THIS WATER HERE.
>> Reporter: ALL RIGHT.
THE WIND IS HOLDING THE WATER
THERE.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR ABOUT THE
FAMILY THAT OWNS THE MARINA, IT
MAY BE GONE.
ALTHOUGH, IT IS HEARTENING TO
KNOW THAT THEY THEMSELVES ARE
OKAY.
BILL, EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE WE
GET THIS REALLY POUNDING RAIN.
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING IN TERMS OF
RAIN THERE?
>> Reporter: WE'RE GETTING THESE
BANDS NOW.
WE SAW THE 80, 90-MILE-PER-HOUR
GUSTS FOR A FEW MINUTES A FEW
HOURS AGO.
NOW IT'S PROBABLY IN THE
30-MILES-PER-HOUR RANGE.
STILL DANGEROUS.
WE'RE TAKING SHELTER BEHIND ONE
OF THESE GRAND TREES THAT ARE
HERE.
BUT WE'VE SEEN PLENTY OF THIS
CORRUGATED STEEL SHEETING, TIN
ROOFS BLOWING AROUND, PEELING
OFF HERE.
BUT, AGAIN, JUST TO SORT OF
LEVEL WHAT THE LOCALS WERE
TELLING US, LAST NIGHT WE WENT
OUT ON A SHORT BOAT CRUISE IN
THE CALM BEFORE THE STORM WITH A
LOCAL CAPTAIN HERE WHO SAID HE
WAS WORRIED THAT THE SURGE WOULD
REACH THE ROOF LINE OF THE
DOCKSIDE GRILL RIGHT THERE.
IT CAME UP A FEW FEET INSIDE,
BUT NOWHERE NEAR THEIR WORST
FEARS.
THAT GIVES YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE
THAT PROBABLY COULD HAVE BEEN A
LOT WORSE IN THIS AREA.
AS FAR AS WHAT'S HAPPENING
FURTHER UP, KEATON BEACH, ALL OF
THAT, WE DON'T KNOW YET.
IT'S TOO SOON TO TELL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE DON'T HAVE EYES ON SOME OF
THESE OTHER AREAS WHERE THE
STORM SURGE COULD BE WORSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
PLEASE STAY SAFE AND PLEASE KEEP
US POSTED OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
HOURS AS WELL.
BILL DESCRIBING WHAT HE'S SEEING
IN STEINHATCHEE THERE, A TOWN OF
500 TO 1,000 PEOPLE DEPENDING ON
THE TIME OF THE YEAR.
WHAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH WHICH
IS QUITE BAD AND STILL
DEVELOPING RIGHT NOW, LET'S GO
NOW DOWN TO TAMPA.
OBVIOUSLY, ONE OF THE MAJOR
METROPOLITAN CENTERS OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA WHERE WHILE THE
STORM DID NOT MAKE A DIRECT HIT
THERE, NOT AT ALL THE STORM
SURGE THERE HAS BEEN A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
DEREK VAN DAM IS THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> THE WIND CONTINUES TO PUSH UP
THE WATER FROM TAMPA BAY AS
WELL, JOHN.
WE ARE GETTING NOW THESE
INTERMITTENT TROPICAL FEEDER
BANDS AND WHAT WAS COMPLETELY
VISIBLE ACROSS TAMPA BAY HAS NOW
BEEN OBSCURED BY HEAVY SHEETS OF
RAIN COMING IN.
IT'S RAINING AT QUITE A CLIP.
PROBABLY A GOOD HALF AN INCH TO
AN INCH PER HOUR.
THIS WILL CAUSE LOCALIZED INLAND
FLOODING.
THIS IS ALL WORKING TOGETHER TO
CREATE THE VERY DIFFICULT STORM
SURGE CONDITIONS THAT YOU SEE
UNFOLDING BEHIND US ON BAY SHORE
BOULEVARD.
THIS AREA FLOODS DURING RAINY
DAYS.
IT HAPPENS.
BUT THIS IS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE SURGE OF WATER THAT HAS BEEN
PUSHED UP WITH THIS MAJOR
HURRICANE.
THE INLAND FLOODING MEETING IT
AT THE SAME TIME.
AND THEN ALSO THE EXAGGERATED
TIDES FROM THE SUPERMOON AND THE
FULL MOON THAT'S HAPPENING AS WE
SPEAK.
WE JUST WENT THROUGH THE LOW
TIDE CYCLE.
THAT WAS AT 7:56 THIS MORNING.
WE'RE WORKING OUR WAY BACK UP
INTO HIGH TIDE.
SO THE CONCERN HERE IS THAT THE
SURGE THAT ALREADY BROKE RECORD
LEVELS -- ONE OF THOSE GUSTS
THAT COME THROUGH.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE SURGE
LATER THIS AFTERNOON, ROUGHLY
2:00 P.M., ARE GOING TO BE
EXACERBATED BY ALL OF THESE KIND
OF -- A COMPANY OF ISSUES HERE,
THE SUPERMOON, THE STORM SURGE,
THE PUSH OF THE WATER FROM THE
STORM AND THAT'S GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE EVEN FURTHER
STORM SURGE FLOODING CONCERNS
HERE ALONG THE TAMPA BAY REGION.
TAMPA CAN'T SEE IT, BUT IT IS
OVER MY RIGHT SHOULDER.
WE'VE BEEN HERE ALL DAY AND THE
BAY HAS JUST BEEN ANGRY.
THE WATER PUSHING UP, CREATING
WAVES, SOMETIMES TOWERING OVER
TWO, THREE STORIES SOMETIMES.
AS THESE BANDS COME IN, THEY'RE
STINGING OUR FACE HERE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SPECTATORS FROM
THESE HOUSES THAT HAVE COME TO
SEE THE SCENE UNFOLDING AND, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS DIFFERENT FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THIS ROAD
CAN FLOOD.
BUT WITH THIS AMOUNT OF WATER
LAPPING UP TO THE PROPERTY
LINES, THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
HOMES ARE AT RISK AS WELL.
JOHN, SO MUCH GOING ON HERE.
I'M GOING TO SEND IT BACK TO
YOU.
>> YEAH, DEREK, IF I CAN HANG ON
TO YOU FOR A SECOND LONGER.
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING AND THEY
SHOULDN'T BE IN THIS TOWN.
THE RAIN IS COMING DOWN REALLY
HARD AND I CAN TELL IT'S COMING
DOWN HARD WHERE YOU ARE NOW.
BUT IF I CAN ASK YOU, LEAN ONTO
YOUR EXPERTISE FOR JUST A SECOND
FOR THE STORM SURGE, WE WERE
SPEAKING TO BILL WEIR A MOMENT
AGO IN STEINHATCHEE WHO SAID AT
LEAST THERE IT SEEMS LIKE THE
SURGE FOR NOW MAY HAVE CRESTED.
THEY'RE SEEING IT BACK OFF A
LITTLE BIT AND THEY'RE SEEING A
DEBRIS LINE THERE.
TALK TO US ABOUT HOW THIS COULD
WORK OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL HOURS
UP AND DOWN THE BIG BEND AREA,
EVEN WHERE YOU ARE.
COULD YOU SEE THE SURGE RECEDE
SOME AND THEN COME BACK IN
AGAIN?
>> Reporter: OKAY, THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION.
AND WHAT WE GOT TO DO, WE GOT TO
VISUALIZE HOW A HURRICANE
ROTATES.
COUNTER CLOCKWISE, OKAY?
AND SO I AM ON THE EASTERN SIDE
OF WHERE THAT CENTER OF WHERE
IDALIA MADE LANDFALL, WHERE BILL
WEIR IS LOCATED, I HAVEN'T
CHECKED A MAP, BUT I BELIEVE HE
WOULD BE ON THE BACKSIDE OF THE
STORM.
SO THE WIND DIRECTION WILL BE
COMPLETELY OPPOSITE TO WHAT
WE'RE RECEIVING HERE.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
LET'S COMPARE IT TO IAN FROM
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
THERE IS A MAJOR DIFFERENCE TO
WHAT HAPPENED IN TAMPA BAY THAT
HAD THE WATER SUCKED OUT BECAUSE
OF THE DIRECTION THE WIND WAS
PUSHING OFFSHORE HERE IN TAMPA
VERSUS THE ONSHORE COMPONENT
THAT BROUGHT THE SURGE TO FORT
MYERS BEACH.
THE SAME THING IS HAPPENING
HERE.
WE HAPPEN TO BE IN THE ONSHORE
COMPONENT OF THIS STORM AND THAT
IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO SEE THIS
PUSH, THIS SURGE OF WATER THAT
IS COMING DIRECTLY OFF THE GULF
OF MEXICO.
JOHN?
>> YEAH, IT'S A REALLY GOOD
EXPLANATION, DEREK.
IF YOU CAN -- I CAN'T SEE YOU.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE JUST
GETTING POURED ON OR BLOWN
AROUND NOW OR WHAT.
IF YOU NEED TO GO, LET ME
KNOW --
>> ALL OF THE ABOVE.
>> THIS IS SUCH IMPORTANT
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE BOTH
GOING TO GET WET FOR THE TIME
BEING.
IN TERMS OF THE TIDES, YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE SUPERMOON AND
THE TIDE RISING.
HOW DOES TIDE WORK WITH STORM
SURGE?
STORM SURGE IS INDEPENDENT OF
HIGH TIDE, BUT THE TIDES CAN
MAKE IT WORSE?
>> YEAH, THIS IS INCREDIBLE TO
THINK THE UNFORTUNATE
COINCIDENCE OF THIS TIMING,
RIGHT?
WE HAVE THE HIGH TIDE IN TAMPA
BAY OCCURRING 2:00 P.M. THIS
AFTERNOON.
WE ALSO HAVE THIS SUPERMOON.
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT THAT IS.
SUPERMOON IS ACTUALLY -- WHEN
THE FULL MOON IS AT ITS CLOSEST
APPROACH TO EARTH.
IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT 18,000 MILES
CLOSER THAN IT NORMALLY WOULD BE
ON ITS ELLIPTICAL PATH AROUND
THE PLANET.
WHAT THAT DOES IS IT EXAGGERATES
THE TUG, THE PULL ON THE OCEAN
AND IT EXAGGERATES THE LOW
TIDES, BUT IT ALSO EXAGGERATES
THE HIGH TIDES.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE WHAT IS A
HURRICANE THAT HAS PUSHED UP ALL
OF THIS WATER IN COMBINATION
WITH THIS HIGH TIDE, AND T